(group cheering)
- [Narrator] Residents of Kherson
cheered Ukrainian soldiers,
tore down Russian posters,
and raised Ukrainian flags.
These verified videos posted online
by Ukrainian journalists and officials
show celebrations in Kherson
after Russia retreated from the city.
Just a few weeks earlier,
Russian President Vladimir Putin
claimed and celebrated
the annexation of Kherson,
the only regional capital
that Moscow had captured
since invading Ukraine in February.
The withdrawal from the
strategic southern city
is a major symbolic
defeat for the Kremlin.
We look back at the key
moments in how Russia captured
and then lost Kherson.
(engines rumbling)
This is the day when Russian
tanks rolled into Kherson,
the first major Ukrainian city to fall
during the first few weeks of the war.
(group shouting angrily)
- [Narrator] But soon
after the occupation,
local residents came out
in droves to protest.
Demonstrations lasted for weeks,
(gunfire rattling)
and in some instances, gunshots rang out.
In the following months,
the Kremlin laid out plans
to turn Kherson into a Russian city.
The Russian ruble became an
officially accepted currency,
and Russian citizenship was fast-tracked
for willing residents.
(man speaking foreign language)
- [Narrator] By June, Russian
state media showed footage
of the first Kherson residents
receiving their new documents,
(rocket whooshing)
but around this time,
Washington started shipping
the first units of HIMARS to Ukraine.
These are long-range rocket launchers
and a game-changer in the war.
This enabled Ukrainian troops
to begin targeting bridges
over the Dnipro River, which links Kherson
to other Russian-occupied territories.
As Ukrainian forces started retaking parts
of southern Ukraine, Moscow
held sham referendums in Kherson
and three other regions
asking remaining residents
whether they wanted to join Russia.
A few days later, Putin signed treaties
to annex Kherson and
the other territories,
and celebrations were held in Moscow.
The annexation wasn't recognized
by any foreign government
apart from North Korea.
Only a few weeks after the annexation,
Russia began mass transfer
of residents from Kherson,
saying up to 70,000
people would be evacuated
as Ukrainian forces
advanced toward the city
(Alla speaking foreign language)
- [Narrator] Ukrainian
soldiers also used artillery
to cut off thousands of Russian
troops in and around Kherson
by targeting bridges in the area.
(Sergei speaking foreign language)
- [Narrator] After Moscow said
it had completed its withdrawal,
Ukraine confirmed that its
troops had entered the city,
marking a turning point in the war
and a morale boost for Ukrainians
(Volodymyr speaking foreign language)
- [Narrator] While the retreat
is a political blow for Putin,
Russia still controls
parts of the Kherson region
and Moscow says it will
now hold stronger positions
to the east of Kherson
where it'll be easier
to resupply its troops
as the war grinds on.
(dramatic piano music)